من نيفادا نتائج مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
حصلت لصالح الديمقراطيه
احتفظت بمقادها بمجلس الشيوخ بعد فوزها في
ولايه نيفادا على منافسها الجمهوري ادم
المدعوم من الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
ومع فوزي ماستو في اعقاب اعاده انتخاب
السنه الردموقراطيه
ماركليزونا يسيطر الديمقراطيون الان على
50 مقعدا في مجلس الشيوخ الذي يضم مئه عضو
ما يسمح لحزب بيض بالسيطره على المجلس
باعتبار ان الصوت المرجح يعود الى نائبه
الرئيس
فوز الديمقراطيين حاسم لاستمراريه رئاسه
جوبايتن الذي عبر عن سعادته بالنتائج من
كمبوديا
معتبرا نجاح الديمقراطيين في الانتخابات
النصفيه قد وضعه في موقف اقوى لاجراء
محادثات حاسمه مع نظيره الرئيس الصيني
في السادس من ديسمبر لكن ذلك لم يؤثر في
النتيجه
في مجلس النواب لا تزال عمليات الفرز
مستمره حيث يبدو ان جمهوريين اقرب لسيطره
ولو باغلبيه بسيطه ويفصلهم عن ذلك سبعه
مقاعد فقط فمن اصل 218 مقعدا وهو الرقم
المطلوب للفوز حصل جمهوريون حتى الان على
211 فيما حصل الديمقراطيون على 2003 مقاعد
حتى الان
ملوك الشيخ العربيه